every time there's a jihad terror attack
and every time there's an uncovered plot
for a jihad terror attack the news media
is filled with stories about anti-muslim
backlash local mosque asks for police
protection
the Imam says we're afraid of right-wing
Yahoo's who are going to come and
victimize innocent people dr. Robert
Spencer has been studying Islamic
extremism and reporting it in his books
and his blog jihad watch for more than a
decade
I think establishment media news outlets
must have a template and they just fill
in the blanks with the names and the
dates and the addresses and the name of
the Imam and so on it's always the same
but the one thing that we don't ever get
is actual anti-muslim backlash first
let's go to a credible source to look at
the numbers according to the FBI there
were 257 incidents of hate crimes
against Muslims in the United States in
2015 now that's too many to be sure
however it's really a very small number
if you think about what the news media
will give us the impression of if you
would get the idea that Muslims are
afraid to walk out of their homes for
fear of being attacked by creeps wearing
make America great again hats but in
reality in a population of 300 million
over 365 days is really not that much
and it is as I say dwarfed by
anti-jewish crimes
664 anti-jewish incidents so what
exactly constitutes a hate crime to get
CR T V sign up at CR tv.com and enter
promo code Malkin for a special discount